Alice:就塞一半呗
Alice: Just hide half of it.
其他人:藏这空调扇叶里
Others: Hide it in the air conditioner fins.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha.
其他人:来好
Others: Come on, let's go.
其他人:发挥我的想象力
Others: Use my imagination.
其他人:这不是藏的是贴的
Others: It's not hidden, it's stuck.
Jake:贴上去的
Jake: It's stuck on there.
Lucia:希望他别掉到后面
Lucia: Hope it doesn't fall behind.
Lucia:拿不出来了就行
Lucia: It'll be hard to get out.
Jake:哦这个还挺挺看到
Jake: Oh, this is quite visible.
Jake:挺容易看到的
Jake: It's pretty easy to see.
Lucia:那就下面
Lucia: Then put it below.
Alice:可以拿个胶带
Alice: You can use some tape.
Alice:这样反粘着
Alice: Stick it the other way.
Jake:这个不好
Jake: That's not good.
Lucia:哎我的美文纸到了
Lucia: Oh, my pretty paper has arrived.
Jake:你可以夹进去
Jake: You can clip it in.
Jake:这好夹了
Jake: It's easy to clip.
Alice:不太好夹吧
Alice: Not so easy to clip.
Jake:这肯定有缝
Jake: It definitely has a gap.
Jake:肯定很有缝吧
Jake: It must have a gap, right?
Jake:没有缝吧
Jake: No gap?
Alice:没有
Alice: No.
Jake:没有哈哈
Jake: No? Haha.
Jake:这么结实
Jake: So solid.
Jake:这东西我好像我藏的地方藏的挺好
Jake: This thing, I hid it pretty well.
其他人:我好像我藏的地方藏的挺好
Others: I think I hid mine pretty well.
Shure: 我藏我肚子里一个
Shure: I hid one in my stomach.
其他人:哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha.
Alice:我藏桌子底下一个
Alice: I hid one under the table.
Shure: 藏到我裤子里一个
Shure: Hid one in my pants.
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Alice:甜品台底下放一个
Alice: Put one under the dessert table.
Jake:呃可可以查人人影或者你你你
Jake: Uh, you can check for shadows or you, you, you...
Lucia:就是美纹纸可信
Lucia: It's just masking tape, reliable.
Lucia:今天要用的那个
Lucia: The one we need today.
Jake:能稍微稍微没那么难找一些
Jake: Can it be a little easier to find?
Lucia:没问题
Lucia: No problem.
Jake:也很难找这种
Jake: It's also hard to find this type.
Lucia:我需要掌管美纹纸的神
Lucia: I need the god of masking tape.
Lucia:哈哈要吗
Lucia: Haha, do you want it?
Jake:这就不行
Jake: This won't work.
Alice:没有仪式感一点哈哈
Alice: There's no sense of ceremony, haha.
其他人:就把我藏在那个洗衣机上
Others: Just hide me on top of the washing machine.
其他人:洗衣机上OK
Others: On the washing machine, okay.
其他人:你说啊洗衣机上
Others: You said it, on the washing machine.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha.
Lucia:但是它很便宜
Lucia: But it's very cheap.
Lucia:好像才8毛钱还是多少钱
Lucia: Seems like it's only 8 cents or something.
其他人:看我估计长得像是在洗衣机上
Others: Look, I guess it looks like it's on the washing machine.
Lucia:一共吗还是一角
Lucia: Total or just a dime?
Lucia:一共
Lucia: Total.
其他人:其他人:然后我就然后就过去一拿就拿出来
Others: And then I just went and grabbed it.
Jake:哪啊哪个洗衣机上
Jake: Which washing machine?
Jake:其他人:
Jake: Others:
Jake:哪呢
Jake: Where?
Jake:洗衣机上
Jake: On the washing machine.
Jake:嘿嘿嘿
Jake: Hehehe.
Shure: 谜底就在谜面上
Shure: The answer is on the surface.
Jake:这个这个吗
Jake: This one?
Jake:是这个吗
Jake: Is it this one?
其他人:卧槽找到
Others: Wow, found it!
其他人:你哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Others: You hahaha...
Lucia:什么呀
Lucia: What?
Jake:这个很圆这个
Jake: This is very round, this one.
Shure: 这呢确实特别像那什么
Shure: This one indeed looks a lot like something.
Lucia:花瓶啊底下有一个呀好
Lucia: A vase, there's one under it, okay.
Alice:那草底下能藏吗
Alice: Can it be hidden under the grass?
Shure: 藏过
Shure: Hidden before.
Alice:这个这个藏过了吗
Alice: Has this one been hidden before?
Lucia:草底下我藏了一个你有看到吗
Lucia: I hid one under the grass, did you see it?
Alice:哦看到了
Alice: Oh, I saw it.
Shure: 你要把我音响拆
Shure: You want to take apart my speakers
Shure: 你咋不把我拆了呢
Shure: Why don't you just take me apart too
Shure: 哎
Shure: Ugh
Alice:这个底下有吗
Alice: Is there anything underneath this
Lucia:这个底下好像没有
Lucia: It doesn't seem like there's anything underneath
Lucia:但这音箱明天会放在这吗
Lucia: But will this speaker be here tomorrow
Lucia:有可能会放嗯
Lucia: It might be, yeah
Jake:有可能会挪对
Jake: It might be moved, though
Jake:有意思
Jake: Interesting
Jake:烤箱能烤好吗我去
Jake: Can the oven bake well, I wonder
Lucia:院子里能放吗
Lucia: Can we put it in the yard
Jake:院子可以放
Jake: The yard is fine